We can finally go ahead and
introduce the basic elements
of the Bayesian
inference framework.
There is an unknown
quantity, which
we treat as a random variable,
and this is what's special
and why we call this the
Bayesian inference framework.
This is in contrast
to other frameworks
in which the unknown
quantity theta is just
treated as an unknown constant.
But here, we treat it
as a random variable,
and as such, it
has a distribution.
This is the prior distribution.
This is what we
believe about Theta
before we obtain any data.
And then, we obtain some data,
which are some observation.
That observation is
a random variable,
but when the process
gets realized,
we observe an actual
value, numerical value,
of this random variable.
The observation
process is modeled,
again in terms of a
probabilistic model.
We specify the
distribution of X,
but we actually specify the
conditional distribution of X.
We say how X will
behave if Theta happens
to take on a specific value.
These two pieces, the prior and
the model of the observations,
are the two components
of the model
that we will be working with.
Once we have obtained a specific
value for the observations,
then we can use the
Bayes rule to calculate
the conditional
distribution of Theta,
either a conditional
PMF if Theta is discrete
or a conditional PDF
if Theta is continuous.
And this will be a complete
solution, in some sense,
of the Bayesian
inference problem.
There's one philosophical issue
about this framework, which
is where does this prior
distribution come from?
How do we choose it?
Sometimes we can choose it
using a symmetry argument.
If there's a number of
possible choices for Theta
and there's a reason to
believe that they're all
equally likely,
we have no reason
to believe that one is more
likely than the other, then
the symmetry consideration
gives us a uniform prior.
We definitely take into
account any information
we have about the range
of the parameter Theta,
so we use that range and we
assign 0 prior probability
for values of Theta
outside the range.
Sometimes, we have some
knowledge about Theta
from previous studies of a
certain problem, that tell us
a little bit about
what Theta might be,
and then when we obtain
new observations,
we refine those results
that were obtained
from previous studies by
applying the Bayes rule.
And in some cases,
finally, the choice
could be arbitrary or subjective
just reflecting our beliefs
about Theta, some
plausible judgment
about the relative likelihoods
of different choices of Theta.
Now, as we just discussed,
the complete solution
or the complete answer to a
Bayesian inference problem
is just the specification of
the posterior distribution
of Theta given the particular
observation that we
have obtained.
Pictorially, if
Theta is discrete,
a complete answer might be in
the form of such a diagram that
tells us that certain
values of Theta
are possible with
certain probabilities.
Or if Theta is continuous,
a complete solution
might be in the form of a
conditional PDF that again
tells us the conditional
distribution of Theta.
To appreciate the idea
here, consider the problem
of guessing the number
of electoral votes
that a candidate gets in
the presidential election.
The electoral votes
are certain votes
that the candidate
gets from each one
of the states in
the United States.
And there is a certain
number that the candidate
needs to get in order
to be elected president.
One possible prediction
could be a statement
that I predict that
candidate A will win,
but actually a more
complete presentation
of the results of
a poll could be
a diagram of this kind,
which is essentially a PMF.
Here, a particular pollster
collected all the data
and gave the posterior
probability distribution
for the different possible
numbers of electoral votes.
And this diagram is a
lot more informative
than the simple statement that
we expect a certain candidate
to get more than the
required electoral votes.
So what is next?
As we just discussed,
the complete solution
is in terms of a
posterior distribution,
but sometimes, you may want
to summarize this posterior
distribution in a single
number or a single estimate,
and this could be
a further stage
of processing of the results.
So let us talk about this.
Once you have in your hands
the posterior distribution
of Theta, either in a discrete
or in a continuous setting,
and if you're asked to provide
a single guess about what
Theta is, how might you proceed?
In the discrete case, you
could argue as follows.
These values of Theta all
have some chance of occurring.
This value of Theta is the
one which is the most likely,
so I'm going to
report this value
as my best guess
of what Theta is.
And using a similar
philosophy, you
could look at the
continuous case
and find the value of Theta
at which the PDF is largest
and report that
particular value.
This particular way
of estimating Theta
is called the maximum a
posteriori probability rule.
We already have in our hands
the specific value of X,
and therefore, we
have determined
the conditional
distribution for Theta.
What we then do is to
find the value of theta
that maximizes over all possible
thetas the conditional PMF
of this random
variables capital Theta.
And similarly in
the continuous case,
the value of theta that
maximizes the conditional PDF
of the random variable Theta.
This is one way of coming
up with an estimate.
One can think of other ways.
For example, I might want
to report instead, the mean
of the conditional distribution,
which in this diagram
might be somewhere here,
and in this picture,
it might be somewhere here.
This way of estimating theta
is the conditional expectation
estimator.
It just reports the value of
the conditional expectation,
the mean of this
conditional distribution.
It is called the least
mean squares estimator,
because it has a certain
useful and important property.
It is the estimator
that gives you
the smallest mean squared error.
We will discuss this
particular issue
in much more depth
a little later.
Now, let me make two
comments about terminology.
What we have produced
here is an estimate.
I gave you the conditional
PDF or conditional PMF,
and you tell me a number.
This number, the
estimate, is obtained
by starting with the data, doing
some processing to the data,
and eventually, coming up
with a numerical value.
Now, g is the way that
we process the data.
It's a certain rule.
Now, if we know the
value of the data,
we know what the
estimate is going to be.
But if I do not tell you
the value of the data
and you look at the
situation more abstractly,
then the only thing
you can tell me
is that I will be seeing
a random variable,
capital X, I will do
some processing to it,
and then I will obtain
a certain quantity.
Because capital X is random,
the quantity that I will obtain
will also be random.
It's a random variable.
This random variable,
capital Theta hat,
we call it an estimator.
Sometimes, we might also
use the term estimator
to [refer to] the
function g, which
is the way that we
process the data.
In any case, it is important to
keep this distinction in mind.
The estimator is the rule that
we use to process the data,
and it is equivalent to a
certain random variable.
An estimate is the
specific numerical value
that we get when the data take
a specific numerical value.
So if little x is the
numerical value of capital X,
in that case, little theta
hat is the numerical value
of the estimator
capital Theta hat.
So at this point, we have a
complete conceptual framework.
We know, abstractly
speaking, what
it takes to calculate
conditional distributions,
and we have two specific
estimators at hand.
All that's left
for us to do now is
to consider various examples
in which we can discuss what
it takes to go through
these various steps.